l'agression des deux agents de médiation
avait marqué les habitants du quartier
de la fontaine d'ouche le rôle des
médiateurs et de favoriser le dialogue
auprès des habitants l'arrestation des
agresseurs présumés favorablement
accueillie par le président de grand
dijon médiation l'association ne baisse
pas les bras à la suite de cet acte moi
je me réjouis de cette arrestation je te
veel et étant effectivement que les
services de police et je l'espère les
services de justice puisse aller avec
toute la rigueur nécessaire au bout du
travail d'identification des personnes
d'arrestation et puis le traitement
approprié en fonction des résultats des
enquêtes
il n'y a pas de zone de non droit il
doit pas rien à voir donc l'association
gruissan andijan médiation soit
véritablement occuper l'espace l'a fait
et continuera à le faire avec une grande
détermination les agresseurs présumés
ont été appréhendés mercredi matin la
police a arrêté deux frères dont un
mineur le maire de dijon s'est aussi
félicité de cette arrestation mais
souhaite que la sanction soit à la
hauteur de la gravité des actes commis
je veux que la justice passe et de
manière exemplaire car il est
intolérable
ces faits sont intolérables ils ont
choqué l'ensemble de la population
il y avait un troisième individu il
faudra le trouver aussi les médiateurs
font un travail pour les habitants les
habitants ne veulent plus ce type de
comportement donc j'attends que la
justice passe de manière exemplaire
quant aux deux médiateurs agressé l'un
d'entre eux ne souhaite plus continuer
dans cette voie son contrat étant
achevée l'autre est toujours en arrêt de
travail